die mir zu jendrik maske ihm gehört das
fitnessstudio cross fit grenzgänger hier
in berlin
hermann aschwer was erwarten sie sich
was erhoffen sie sich von der politik
heute
ich hoffe mir auf jeden fall einen ganz
klaren fahrplan und des ganzen
ich finde da wird viel zu viel
parteipolitisch hin und her geredet sind
das sind einfach wirklich existenzen
bedroht und es wird viel zu viel in eine
richtung gegangen wenn so sehr wieder
geschützt werden denn kleine betriebe
große betriebe ich finde das sollte
einheitlich und auch wirklich mit
fahrplan
ja uns irgendwie mitgeteilt werden so
dass wir auch wirklich klaren und können
in dieser ansicht und seit nun sind ja
aber betriebe ganz unterschiedlich also
nehmen wir zum beispiel das
fitnesscenter beim sport soll die
übertragung besonders problematisch
seien und deshalb muss man ja sehen
selbst wenn man beispielsweise fitness
center öffnet wie es dann weitergeht
weil das virus bleibt ja haben sie sich
darüber dass jetzt schon mal gedanken
gemacht noch mehr desinfizieren der
geräte ja das machen wir sollen
vornherein schon ich denke auch dass das
nicht das riesenproblem sein wird man
findet da einheitliche lösung man hat
vom platz ja auch ich glaube nicht dass
es jetzt an der sektion scheitern sollte
sondern dass wir ganz klar natürlich
risikogruppen schützen müssen bei mir im
durchschnitt das alter als bei 35 wir
sind jetzt nicht ganz so betroffen
mit den 70 jährigen aber abgesehen davon
denke ich dort ein umdenken der
gesundheitspolitik erst mal stattfinden
weil da sind ja in den letzten jahren
wirklich sehr viel einsparungen haben
stattgefunden und ich denke da sollte
man vielleicht auch irgendwann mal
ansetzen weil sonst wären wir nicht in
die sahara
herr maske dann ganz viel kraft für die
nächste zeit und danke für ihre
einschätzung an diesem tage an denen